[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys und
aber ja heute stehen wir zwei hier an
der front und möchten etwas tolles
backen mit zuschauerin hat sich ein
rezept gewünscht ich muss das erst mal
googeln und auch die aussprache gurgeln
es heißt hat ab juli und es ist ein
georgisches gericht
ich musste okay ich gebe ihr wisst ich
bin ich habe viele stärken ob ich aber
auch eine große schwäche und zwar ist
dass die geografie und ich muss erstmal
georgien google seine freundin mal
gesagt habe was ist so sagten sowohl in
willich georgien vielleicht bei island
vielleicht keine ahnung wo ich habe es
einfach nicht mit geographie okay ich
habe mich damit beschäftigt jetzt weiß
ich aber georgien liegt im nordosten der
türkei
also warte ich mache es für euch einmal
hier wenn hier die türkei ist ist hier
georgien grenzt also direkt an die
türkei ohne freund von uns die sabine
die varta sogar schon mal und hat so
davon geschwärmt dass ich gesagt habe
mensch da müssen wir unbedingt annehmen
jetzt weiß ich was liegt und vielleicht
können wir irgendwann wieder das land
verlassen
also können wir auch irgendwann
hoffentlich drei hinreißen
und da gibt es ein rezept ella und das
heißt rasch ab und ist und ich dachte
mir noch als ich das dann die googles
hab dachte ich mir noch das sieht aus
wie die türkischen peter und ich meine
es liegt ja nahe dass dann angrenzende
länder sowie ähnlichen sitten und
bräuche die ähnlichen rezepte haben also
das ist ein brot gefüllt mit käse ist
nicht so genau wie erbte
ich sage aber total okay und deswegen
werden wir uns heute zu bereiten heute
habe ich die fleißige helferin dabei und
dann wird das natürlich ganz wunderbar
gelingen
jetzt machen wir erstmal den hefeteig
für den teig nehme ich allen würfel hefe
einen teelöffel zucker 250 gramm warmes
wasser 900 gramm mehl ich nehme sie
einen dinkelmehl 250 gramm war mit zwei
teelöffel salz 120 gramm sonnenblumenöl
kann nicht allein tun was eigentlich war
ja gar nicht geplant ist oder bei dem
relativ sitzt übernimmst du einfach
wieder alles ja jetzt kannst du dir hier
eingeben ins wasser damit das machen wir
brotteig kate wirst du so ein richtiger
becker da kommt zucker dazu ja ein
bisschen zucker verrühren
ganz vorsichtig kann man nicht sagt
drücken sonst spritzt gleich raus als am
besten so wie sie streicheln und dann
löst sich die hebe gleichauf und
festhalten ja ich hoffe ihr habt zu
hause ab zu einem fleißigen bäcker ein
bäckerlehrling
die hilft lebt immer sogar deswegen muss
man das glas gut festhalten zeigt und
dann gehts ja die preismacht wir sind
dran einem schneebesen doch ein teller
besen okay sonst ist hier ein wegen
super gut und jetzt darfst wo das hefe
wasser in die maschine schützen müsse
man kann natürlich auch mit der hand
verkneten
er war die lg schafft das ja super
dafür nehmen wir gleich eine hilfe sein
die jetzt darfst du ja doch schützt mal
so rein noch nicht alles dafür ist weil
ich mal davon ein bisschen machen dass
die schüssel bisschen leer wird also
ergeben also die hälfte etwa dass sein
vater kurz aber ich zeige dir wie das
klingt okay oder verschicken
ich wüsste nicht dass du mit wachs
deswegen habe ich die hefe das war die
milch nicht in einen aus kies gefäß
gegeben sonst hätte ich es auch in so
einem becher rein
wir machen das so
ja ja die milde strafe zwei natürlich
einen gewissen ja dann kann man immer so
gerade halten
und jetzt noch das sanfte zu fragen
ich glaub mir mama macht gern soll frei
das kneten teig schon mal und nicht
reinpassen bist weißt du dann geben wir
nach und nach noch das restliche mehl
dazu und natürlich auch noch was
natürlich will jetzt einen löffel
nein erstmal das wären dann das öl hatte
kurz
schau mal du nimmst jetzt hier mail so
hatte ich zeige es einmal zeigen es dir
und dann dazu da gibt es hier drauf und
dann rutscht von ganz alleine die
rutschbahn runter die rutschbahn siehst
du das mehl abrutschen
dass man so viel spaß wie dr
wenn wir übrigens winkel mehr verwenden
können natürlich auch weizen benutzen
man hat jetzt gebe ich noch das öl davor
dass das mal hier rein
[Musik]
nadal war stopp es reicht erstmal
weshalb er keine lust mehr
packen wir alleine weiter also so sieht
der teig jetzt aus ist ein schöner
weißer teig der aber auch nicht klebt
wie knete dann immer gerne so sieben bis
zehn minuten
es wird ja wirklich schön geschmeidig
ich habe jetzt ihr übrigens endlich die
edelstahl haken
jetzt dürfen sie endlich in die
spülmaschine
ich bin glücklich denn die anderen die
müssten per hand waschen ist auch okay
aber edelstahl finden sich einfach immer
einfacher ich hab einfach den teig kurz
rausnehmen zu einer kugel formen ich
bestritten dann gerne mit bakterien
spray damit die oberfläche nicht
trocknet und entweder lasst ihn dann
abgedeckt bei raumtemperatur für eine
stunde aufgeben oder bei der stufe wenn
ihr habt im backofen also mit etwas
dampf funktionen dann trocknet er
nämlich auch nicht aus und geht vor
allem ums doppelte schneller auf also
spart man sich echt viel zeit in die
schüssel ein bisschen obendrauf
und da ist es jetzt noch schön
verdoppeln
[Musik]
der teig ist es wunderbar aufgegangen
jetzt braucht ihr nur noch wenige
zutaten um das gericht fertig zu stellen
ich habe jetzt hier 600 gramm schafskäse
300 gramm mozzarella etwas milch zum
bestreichen butter und vier eier also
traditionell wird wahrscheinlich kein
mozzarella verwendet sondern ich habe
jetzt mal recherchiert es gibt auch
verschiedene arten dieses gericht dieses
russia calling denn je nach region auch
in georgien wird es anders geformt ist
sieht anders aus hat anderen käse drin
und zum einen habe ich jetzt gefunden
dass es den 20 juni käse gibt und den
immer mehr und immer uli käse und beide
sind sehr würzig und daher dachte ich
dass es ganz gepasst und die schmelz
eigenschaft von mozzarella ganz gepasst
wir probieren es einfach aus und
irgendwann werde ich nach georgien
hoffentlich und dann probiere es einfach
raus und dann nehme ich bezug auf dieses
rezept und auf dieses video und sagt ja
es war genauso oder nein und dann ja
aber vielleicht könnt ihr wenn ihr aus
georgien seit oder das dort schon mal
gegessen habt mir sagen ob die form
genau so war wie ich jetzt mache oder ob
es anders aussah denn wie gesagt über
alles anders und das hier kommt jetzt
aus dem ort aus der region vergleich der
name noch nicht aussprechen kann
deswegen lass ich es einfach ich bleibe
es hier einfach ein
ja das ist die art des rather police aus
dieser region
diese brote die werden jetzt relativ
groß also nicht wie die türkischen peter
etwas kleines sondern wirklich schön
groß und man gibt dann sozusagen den
käse auch direkt mit dem brot ich werde
jetzt hier raus vier stück zu bereiten
ich denke das passt ganz gut steg eine
portion wer so eine große portion für
jahr zum beispiel oder für zwei frauen
jetzt mit den fraktionen ja je nachdem
wie viel man eben ist
als ich jetzt den teig vierteln und zu
kugeln formen
[Musik]
es war kurz draußen deswegen hatte ich
die tage hier kurz abgedeckt und ich
sehe sie sind wie beste freund zusammen
gewachsen
ja ich musste dann kurz nach dem garten
und jetzt nehme ich diesen teig das war
wunderschön weich ist und rolle im oval
aus schön groß
[Musik]
die könnte theoretisch auch auf pizza
blechen warum ich wollte auch zuerst auf
den ackerflächen backen aber die sind
glaube ich einfach etwas zu groß die
schiffe daher nehme ich jetzt doch mein
lochblech und seine back folie das lasso
kurz liegen
mach das jetzt ganz kurz mit allen
vieren
ich finde das arbeiten mit teig hat
etwas beruhigen
vor allem mit hefeteig
[Musik]
ich hatte jetzt noch baby mozzarella da
versuchte einmal zu reiben
ja das geht
ich reite mozzarella natürlich könnt ihr
auch großen mozzarella nehmen aber ich
hatte jetzt den da und wollte nicht
extra einkaufen gehen denn ich habe
wirklich für dieses gericht alle zutaten
in mathe schafskäse sowieso mozzarella
habe ich nicht immer aber zufall
und deswegen wird als gerieben und auch
der feta-käse gerieben
[Musik]
der schafskäse lässt sich etwas leichter
regen
[Musik]
den käse habe ich jetzt noch schön durch
gerührt war ja gerade davon geträumt ich
glaube das rezept schmeckt am besten aus
so einem richtig genial steinofen oder
holzofen
irgendwann werden wir einem garten haben
vielleicht ag und jetzt einfach nur den
käse vierteln deswegen auch eine große
käse menge da drinnen
ich glaube tatsächlich dass mein käse
gar nicht ausreicht ich komme gleich mal
also ich wollte sowieso erst erst formen
ihr könnt wenn ihr möchtet sogar noch
lauter hat zum beispiel zur sticks
schneiden und dann käse im rand noch
einpacken
ja ich da ein habe mir da echt was ein
okay wir machen käse im rannte ich würde
solche sticks machen
ich hoffe die sind jetzt dünn genug das
ist auch schön formen kann wenn es
nichts wird lassen wir es halt weg mein
gott war es eine gute idee aber
vielleicht mache ich sie halb so lang
und damit flexibel bleibt jetzt beim
formen also da jetzt noch käse im rand
machen fange ich jetzt hier nochmal neu
an
ich zeig euch hier belegen den käse
hierhin so etwa zwei zentimeter vom rand
weg hier oben nicht sondern wirklich nur
an die seiten
[Musik]
jetzt wird hier der rand umgeschlagen
denn ich habe das bild gesehen von
diesem kater pulli dann habe sie in dem
diesen wunderschönen wunderschönen
dicken rand und ich glaube so haben wir
einfach schon diesem schönen linken rand
und das ende hier nehmt ihr jetzt ich
bin ein bisschen schiff förmige und
zwirbelt es einfach so ganz einfach am
besten formt ihr euch zuerst alle und
dann füllt ihr sie oh ja
so fällt es mir gut ich war kommt jetzt
käsereien also das rezept ist definitiv
was wird helfe liebhaber
[Musik]
das wäre jetzt nicht sofort gebacken
sondern wird nochmal abgedeckt darf noch
ein bisschen aufgehen
das heißt ich mache jetzt hier noch alle
anderen fertig und mache jetzt alle mit
käse rand aber ich muss kurz darauf
[Musik]
dieser im schrank oder also wenn ihr
sagt euch dass das käsebrot verhältnis
zum heftig dann also wenn ihr sagt ihr
seid so normale käseliebhaber dann
lassen sich so ich mir gesagt mensch ich
jetzt schon gerne einiges zum dippen
dann füllt gern noch die lücken mit käse
auf ich glaube es mache ich jetzt kurzum
für sie noch auf aber ich habe keinen
job und kein lokal am normalen käse
sally art ich habe den käse rein und
dann wird der rand jetzt noch mit etwas
milch gestrichen und wie gesagt denke
ich sehr applus nur noch kurz ruhen und
dann werden sie gepackt und da ist es
dann so dass ich sie backen werde und so
etwa fünf minuten vor ende der backzeit
schlag ich noch ein rein denn so gehört
das
[Musik]
er sitzt hier machte aufgezeigt einfach
den rand ein bisschen mit milch
bestreichen
[Musik]
und dann sofort im vorgeheizten backofen
oder im steinbackofen oder holzofen
gebacken
fünf minuten vor ende der garzeit
schlaglicht auf ein rein
ich glaub ich nämlich spitzer stufe aber
ihr könnt auch einfach über unterschied
zu nehmen
ich sehe sehr gut aus das an die ersten
zwei exemplare sind fertig es kommt hier
nehmen sie in die mitte ein loch
also eine vertiefung perfekt ist der
käse geworden
richtig gut
und dann schlag ich jetzt mal rein hab
ich schlags nicht direkt hier rein
sondern erstmal in ein schälchen damit
keine eierschale auf dem gehweg landet
[Musik]
und so kommt jetzt wieder zurück in den
backofen wird kurz noch mal gebacken so
dass das eiweiß stockt aber es ist ein
schritt flüssig bleibt
ich denke fünf minuten sollten reichen
vielleicht auch kürzer
ich gucke mir einfach gleich an
[Musik]
ich hole jetzt hier einfach noch paar
kräuter aus dem garten
ich glaube da passen ganz gut dazu ein
bisschen thymian bisschen minze
petersilie war eigentlich auch ganz gut
aber die habe ich jetzt nicht egal
nikon petra 7
[Musik]
fertig jetzt habe ich hier noch kräuter
aus dem garten
die hat glaube ich eigentlich gar nicht
dazu aber ich finde es einfach schön
wenn man das projekt oben drauf ist ich
finde es ein bisschen pervers aber ich
habe gelesen dass da noch ein stück
butter rein muss also hier so aber
anscheinend war das auch immer so
seemanns kost war dass ich brauche eine
gabel und sieben männer brauchen halt
kraft und energie
also ich bräuchte jetzt kein stück
butter doch noch mit rein denn der krise
ist schon reichhaltig genug und jetzt
schon so lange daran gelassen
du bist du zu lang mit mit dem 1
also fünf minuten sind definitiv zu lang
am besten noch zwei minuten
aber egal der käse tipp ist perfekt also
manchmal wird sie zu lieben sind die mag
kann auch ohne da darf nicht mehr nur
mal probieren sondern sarah der dem kaum
herein sarah muss auch probieren ja denn
sarah hatte ein kleines fauxpas es kommt
gerade richtig dieses essen mit ihrem
essen
das mache gangelt rottluff cover damit
also hat er seine kleine suppe und jetzt
kommts mittagessen welches findest du
schöner fürs foto zum anderen das foto
[Gelächter]
echt
da sieht man halt das nun ja ich meine
die form
achso für die promis ist noch unklar da
gerade noch mal drauf und dann machen
wir das machen wir jetzt mal gleich
erstmal erst mal probieren erstmal also
wie gesagt stell dir das so vor als wäre
das ein noch so hat gar ich probiere es
hallt es so flüssig ich mich bestimmt
trotzdem gut aber das noch mal auf die
nächsten 2 warten und dann probiert oder
wir probieren beides und ich hab dann
okay also warum soll
und jetzt macht man es wohl so dass
warte noch nicht machen da drauf weil
ist wächst das schild findet man stets
minze minze und zehn jahren jetzt nimmt
man sich von hier aus nun zum stück und
rechts wächst auch und dann tippt man
muss so rein und ist das brot mit käse
tipp immer ist praktisch von außen den
kompletten rand und wenn man ihnen
ankommen kann gabel und messer nehmen ja
[Musik]
kälte von deluxe so richtig käsefondue
importen
ich kriege es nicht
also wenn ihr machen wollte unbedingt
mal ausprobieren ich mache jetzt gleich
das zweite version mit nur zwei minuten
ein
ich glaube im holzofen braucht sogar
noch kürzer was war ich hatte angst dass
genießen musst du auch ich hörte wie
will das brot an atmen gast also viel
spaß beim nachmachen was ich noch rein
machen wird ich würde echt so nach dem
backen und eine knoblauchzehe so ein
bisschen reifer und so dazu das würde
ich den butter und ob sie nicht auch
also mein tipp ohne butter dach ein
bisschen mit knoblauch und dann einfach
dieses leckere brot genießen ist immer
schwierig
[Musik]